Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner Development Team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
the difference between crawled locations and audited items. And this is because a question
we get asked quite frequently is, well, what's the difference? Specifically, if I hop into Burp
here where I've got a finished crawl and audit of Portswiggers' Honorable Web Application Gin
and Juice Shop, we can see that we've got 47 locations crawled. But if I hop over to the
audit items view, you can see that there's 50 none. So why is this? What's the difference?
Well, what it comes down to is the fact that when the crawl is running, we are crawling the web
application like a user and we treat distinct web pages as locations. Whereas when the audit is
running, we are auditing HTTP messages. So there's a bit of a difference between a HTTP message and a
web page, which I'll go over now. To do this, I'm going to use the new crawl paths view, which came
out in 2023.5. My view here might differ a little bit from your view if you open up Burp now. That's
because I'm running an internal build and we're actually constantly, like the guys behind me
somewhere there, are constantly working on this right now. So if you see any differences, just treat
them as sneak previews and don't worry about them too much. So as I said, yeah, I've got Gin and Juice
shop open and we can see all of the actions that the crawler has taken. So for example, we clicked on
new details here for one of the products. And then we see on that product page, we've got a form that
we submitted for checking the stock. We've got an add to cart form. So this is where the difference
between crawled locations and ordered items comes in. When we submitted the form add to cart, we got to a
new page in the web application. That web page had this destination URL here, but there are actually two
bits of HTTP traffic required to build the page. One to fetch the product page, which actually matches
the destination URL of the page. Now this would actually be the URL in the address bar in the
browser. That's where we get the URL from for a page. There's also the second request, which is a
post request to go and... Oh, I've clicked on add to cart. I think I was saying check, stop, but no mind.
So yeah, add cart. So we've got this request here to go and add the product to the cart, which is a
post request. So this is where in this case, we would have one crawled location, but two
ordered items for each of these requests. This can actually go the other way as well. So we've got this
subscribe form on the homepage, which when you click on it has single page app behavior where some
JavaScript runs, but there are no HP messages sent at all. So in this case, we would have a crawl
location, but no audit items. So this is how over time we can build up a difference in that number
because we're constantly crawling web pages as locations. So if I actually hop into Gin and Juke
Shop, I can show this. So this would be a location. If we click on a view details, that would be a
location. Yeah, these are all distinct locations with their URLs coming from the address bar. Whereas
the, as I said, the requests that are issued to build these pages, these locations are what are sent to
the audit. So hopefully that clears things up a little bit. And this is also why, for example,
if you know of some addresses that are requests, some, some addresses that are navigated to in your
application, they might not appear in the audit items view, because if you've got a fully single
page application, you might be browsing around the address bar might be changing, but we're actually
not generating any requests. So there's nothing to audit or the requests that are generated might be
API requests. So the URLs, their paths in this audit items view here might not match what you're
expecting to see in the address bar. So as I said, we're actually still constantly working on this
crawl paths view. This is based on user feedback and there's plenty of goodies we've internally got
lined up to add plenty of new features. So yeah, keep that feedback coming and stay tuned.